so I'm doing the show with Knoxville and
I know he's gonna prank me and he's hard
to prank back because he feels no pain
so I called Jeff and I was like Jeff
what do I do that's a lose-lose if I hit
Knoxville with a prank he's gonna hit
back tenfold and Jeff just goes you
gotta hit him back so I have like a stun
gun next to my bed and I like slowly
take this long thing awkwardly out of my
clothes and I just nail him right in the
chest with him but the guy is like James
Bond villain he was just getting
electrocuted and then he just like
grabbed it out of my hand and then he
had another weapon in his pocket already
and he started nailing me with both stun
guns the next day stung on me in the
neck and it was like the most
unbelievable band I mean you guys have a
high pain tolerance and not really
that can't be true I would put jellyfish
on your head right but it just means
that our desire for attention outweighs
our desire for comfort